we live the galaxy's greatest journey
and go beyond the film to experience
exclusive all new stories don't worry
boss I got us the best raft our hunters
in the sister aunt ravenous rat ours
with Han and Chewie you ready for that
Chewie
now dr. katana in speed so we can climb
myself bouncing what was there even
through foil the first orders plants
with a prince and corsair
good luck finding your pilot's discover
the secrets of jakku with lor san tekka
my transports are yours
it's PO Damron I'm here to rescue you
rescue Admiral Ackbar with Poe Dameron
our transport will be up ahead Admiral
we're just gonna have to fight our way
out of here
there's a better not be a trap discover
hidden secrets we need the location of
the resistance base unravel galactic
mysteries and plane must have stories
for any Star Wars fan that you can't
play anywhere else
featuring all new dialogue from the
force awakens cast it's about time you
showed up repairs completed sir just
need the load fuel and ammo and wookie
cookies for Chewie